calling the SEC championship game
between Alabama and Georgia Brockman I
think he called in prior to last year's
SEC right so this like the Masters on
CBS is a tradition unlike any other Brad
Nessler here on the Rich Eisen show the
day before the SEC Championship game
right Brad would you agree how are you
my friend
I'm dr. grey I'm great to talk to you
too you are obviously in Atlanta already
correct I am my city
everybody thinks because I live here
that it's a home game for me they don't
understand that with that comes the
request for tickets and in my time and
everything helps come on
there cannot be requests for tickets to
a Georgia played SEC championship game
in Atlanta Brad come on now oh it's
great yeah I know 12 12 months ago we
had this problem in Georgia played
Auburn and then 11 months ago there was
a little issue with Georgia playing
Alabama for all the marbles at
mercedes-benz dairyman's right 65 days
from now I'll have requests because it's
a CBS year or a Super Bowl in Atlanta
and we'll be seeing you will be seeing
you for for that week but right now
we've got an SEC championship game what
is Nick Saban like in the in the pre
broadcast meeting with you and gary
Danielson and the rest of the crew he's
actually one of the best coaches that we
deal with to be honest with you and
people find that shocking because they
tend to watch his press conferences on
Monday when he's at the podium with his
bottle of coca-cola and he's pretty much
putting everybody in their place
you know I've known Nick since he was
Bill Belichick's defensive coordinator
at the Cleveland Browns before even got
Michigan State job and you know
subsequently the places he's been so I
think the fact that we've known each
other forever same thing with Gary
there's a mutual respect there so he
maybe treats us a little bit better than
he does some people but I I enjoy my
time with Nick and and a lot of people
find that a little bit shocking well I
mean so even for a week like this he
doesn't come in
any difference what do you what do you
glean from him I know we do you think
that's that's Nick that's why Nick is so
good he treats every game like it's the
SEC championship of the national
championship there is no wasted time
when we meet them in Tuscaloosa it's
exactly at 11:30 on Friday morning his
cup of coffee has been placed just to
his right hand which is right by my left
elbow at the table in the conference
room everything is the same that'll be a
little bit different today because we'll
meet him over at mercedes-benz Stadium
so I'm not quite sure where the coffee
is coming from but now he doesn't change
much and it's the attention to detail at
practice at those meetings not wasting
in time we'll know exactly when it's
time to say okay I think we're done
asking questions because he will get
that little smile like okay guys are you
done and that'll be over yeah same thing
with Kirby actually they're pretty
similar that was well I mean obviously
Kirby smarts comes from the Saban school
we all know that I mean does that still
matter now I mean years it's not their
first rodeo against each other is that
still a reasonable rational germane
storyline Brett I don't think I don't
think scurvy doesn't like it anymore you
know he has even made the statement this
week you know I don't want to talk about
Alabama I'm in the third year as a head
coach at my alma mater we're pretty damn
good team you know
and I think Nick's tired of talking
about being 15 and all against his
former assistants it's just you know
it's a huge game they're obviously
friends but you meet a lot of friends in
this business when you're coaches and I
think they're just let's get on with the
task at hand and not play that card
anymore Brad Nessler of CBS before the
SEC championship game joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show the narrative is
that George isn't the same team from
last year obviously we're watching Sony
Michelle and Nick Chubb do what they're
doing for the Patriots and browns
respectively so that might just be as
obvious as it sounds however let's get
to the granular level is George George
is not the same team that almost took
Alabama down in the National Champion
game last year correct they're not rich
but when you start looking at Elijah
Holyfield
deandre Swift's numbers and once they
get through this game and whatever bowl
game you're gonna find out that it's
pretty similar eerily similar to what
Nick and Sony did a year ago you know
they're not as well known because this
is their first year really being the two
stars in the backfield but I think
Georgia's ground game is just as healthy
as it was this time last year they're
number one in the SEC 260 yards a game
you know if Alabama keeps those two to
say 150 instead of 260 I think you know
they're playing in to the hands of
Alabama's defense
Alabama's defense is getting better
Georgia is getting better both teams are
better than they were two months ago
you know Georgia loss to LSU badly I
think can't they state with the running
attack I don't think they've lost that
game and I think if they played LSU ten
times they'd win eight of them so you
know we could conceivably have two
undefeated teams that would have been
great but will will still settle for
number one again I'm sure yeah well we
saw last night in Thursday Night
Football bred that a front seven that
can get after it and a back end of a
defense that can can plaster with the
front seven getting after it can derail
a a high-flying offense with a
quarterback that is red-hot
now obviously Drew Brees has more
experience under his belt than tool I'm
wondering if Georgia has the game plan
with the running game you just discussed
and the defense to try and shock in the
same manner that the Cowboys just did
last night you know that is a perfect
comparison if if there was a blueprint
that's the thing with to uh as well just
like drew last night
you know they got pressure he doesn't
like pressure in his face up the middle
drew doesn't either because he's you
know six feet tall or whatever two is
the same size they don't like to have to
look over those big guys and you know a
Cowboys played great last night on
defense yes
Georgia had the kinetic guys on their
side of the ball that the Cowboys had
that would be the perfect blueprint
because - it doesn't like guys around
his knees he doesn't elect eyes in his
face the perimeter pressure doesn't bug
him that much but when he's got to step
up in the pocket and make the throws
that he makes he gets a little bit
uncomfortable not as Georgia have those
guy
they haven't had good success sacking
the quarterback this year they had four
against Kentucky I think that was their
season-high they would love to have you
know if Georgia had the front for that
Alabama has then you would be going
that's going to be a problem for
Alabama's offense unfortunately they
don't have the same kind of guys so you
then get some kind of pressure up the
middle they got the Andre Baker on the
back end that can maybe take away half
the field but you know you also got five
receivers that I think are all high
draft choices including herb Smith for
Alabama those cats are unbelievable
receivers and you can't cover them all
couple more minutes left with Brad
Nessler prior to calling the SEC
Championship game on CBS at 4:00 Eastern
with gary Danielson and the rest of the
CBS crew all right let's go hypothetical
and macro I had Desmond Howard on the
show yesterday he called it illogical to
think that an Alabama loss would mean
that it's still not one of the top four
teams in the country for the right to
play for the national championship do
you believe that the result of the game
tomorrow is does not have any
significance in terms of Alabama making
the final four Brad I think they're in
and I just don't see you know and I'm
not trying to be a shill for the SEC
rich or Alabama or whatever I've seen
them five times in person it's going to
be six times tomorrow I watched a lot of
other games and you know I've watched
Ohio State I've watched Oklahoma if one
of those teams plays Alabama Alabama
will put 60 points on both those teams
with their defense and if they have to
but if Alabama is not one of the best
four teams then I'm watching the wrong
game they've been number one since the
beginning they're beating people you
know by 36 points average the closest
team to him was Texas A&M I think I did
that game and I think they lot they won
by 22 whatever it was I just don't get
it I mean I love the argument I know
people want different people in there
they get sick of Alabama all that I
understand that but if they're not one
of the best four teams I'm watching the
wrong game so would you agree that the
the team that's still remaining amongst
the Possible's to take on Alabama and
derail their national championship hopes
is the team that's facing them on
Saturday I think I think there's I think
there's two teams right now that if you
just said okay I'm gonna throw a team up
against Alabama and they can beat him I
that are equipped at least to beat them
Clemson's one and Georgia's the other
one I don't see anybody else even close
no that sounds crazy
including Notre Dame don't think the
defense is I don't well you know what I
don't watch Notre Dame enough and I
shouldn't I shouldn't have excluded them
I'm sorry about that but you know Mikey
Rico's call in those games are all I'm
calling I know likes Ryan's oh well I
know I know it's just it's it's you know
we're talking about it already with Duke
and college basketball we're talked
about it with Golden State everybody
just feels that just handed a hand
Alabama the trophy right now Brad yeah
well I you know it's gonna be
interesting I think tomorrow will tell
us a big tail on you know we say that
every week I guess you know you get to
the Iron Bowl you get to whatever game
you go well now we're going to find out
if Alabama is really going to get you
know pushed Gary and I have been using
that thing all season long so we'll
probably use it again tomorrow let's see
how good they are well have a great cast
Brad really appreciate you taking the
time the day before to chime in and and
I will see you at the Super Bowl if not
before in Atlanta I think you're I think
you're buying when you get here Oh Brad
you are one of my favorites your your
your all your all hotel bar all-time
Brad you're up there you are oh I know
that area you five stars your five stars
thanks again Brad appreciate it but you
bet that's Brad Nessler at Brad
underscore nessler CBS on Twitter Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience